bonjour n'y a pas de madame bardot
il faut en tenir compte oui c'est en ce
monde s'est étendue aux pays-bas où toi
ce que tu fais là c'est parce que les
rapports la rotation interne
bon écoute je sais pas ce qu'on peut
raconter commémoratif a beaucoup
d'influencé sur la qualité le sceau du
mois qu'en réponse à tout
[Musique]
coaching avec vous là bas toujours à
poser des questions tout ce qui vient de
se barrer la merde tiens
on parle d' autisme allégée sans
déficience intellectuelle
je suis tombé sur le foot cette
ingérence en piste au numéro 9 cents
dépasse comme le font ils s'étaient
lecavalier
combien se déplaçant au total à 7% du
jeu on a toujours sur les neuf où elle
fut comme les échecs en fait ouais c'est
une grande chance pour l'us tendance et
vous serez tous risques je ne suis pas
son père je regarde juste quelques jours
j'ai discuté avec les gens de direction
il regarder le haut tu sais on sera dans
une semaine dans un établissement
spécialisé
t'es pas obligée du foot
si l'on a réussi ce test c'est une
grande victoire d'abord sur son handicap
et ensuite parce que ça peut lui offrir
une vie meilleure
la réalité c'est que ça va plus dans les
ronces il est plus dans l'errance tout à
fait sortis
je suis parce que j'ai un moment donné
vous allez vous résumer vous allez
réaliser le doublé mais aussi à décharge